I
it's my pleasure to introduce to you dr.
evil fish dr. evil fish is the founder
and the managing partner of the Python
Quan ski mb ha he's also a lecturer in
mathematical finance at saarland
university and he's written two books
about Python and finance so Eve take it
away Thanks volunteer happy to see a
couple of year of the lunch so I hope
you you won't fall asleep I do my best
for I start and go into interactive
analytics of large financial data sets
how many of you work or working in
finance or in something related and not
too many should have marketed is
different target kroos oh yeah i think
the things that I represented a also
kind of useful for other areas of course
I mean Python is not constrained to the
finance area it has become a little bit
more popular recently with large banks
like Bank of America and for example
JPMorgan making heavy use of Python also
larger hedge funds that were known to be
heavy Python users for example partners
of course that you might all use is an
outgrowth of of a hedge fund actually
where they have problems with managing
time series data financial time series
data with Python so when we can you
started back then working on something
similar to our or we come to that later
on another question how many of you are
using ipython everybody so it's kind of
over the years whenever asking this
question it's kind of like exponential
growth I think we are no it looks like a
cumulative distribution function we now
nearing a hundred percent so and I sense
everybody's using it to some extent at
least of course what I present here and
you might notice it this kind of an eye
Python notebook base presentation html5
if you go to my Twitter feed you will
find the link so just google me up on
Twitter you will find the link to the
slides when you're interested in but you
can also have a look at the URL up there
it's hosted on my private websites will
be strong
a few words about myself I mean Valentin
already mentioned most of it I want to
maybe highlight two more points as he
said doing consulting training
technology I'm lecturer but then also
co-organized of the for Python ones
conference in New York James mentioned
it in the talk earlier and we will bring
that most probably the Sultan to London
in cooperation most probably with cqf
and future learning and I'm also
organizing to meetup groups so if you
are a chance based in Berlin you might
consider Omid approved Python big data
analytics so hit our inaugural meet up
back then in may with also kind of a
good participation if you are in finance
I happened to be in London maybe I'm
running the Python want finance group
there this for like point-of-view kind
of a successful thing we had in total
since May for different events and this
is kind of a wider and community is
similar to New York we also right now I
have a Python for quantifying school
which will have the first meet up next
week so if you able to sit in the things
there are lots of ways to interact with
us actually I've written the book Python
for finance I finish my anything so far
so I'm waiting for O'Reilly to get the
copy editing right and it will be
printed most probably and will be
available in November so the early the
early release version is available as
ebook and we will release chapter after
chapter when O'Reilly says that's fine
so if you understood in that you might
have a look many of the examples that I
present I've taken out of the book that
you will see today ipython why is it so
popular I mean many people come to
python by our ipython because in recent
past when you think back many many years
when we started our 10 years ago using
Python for finance it was already kind
of a nice language with a nice syntax
but nice tools were missing back then
mainly so today it's a little bit the
other way around we have so nice tools
other languages other ecosystems are
eager to like adapt that I mean that the
recent development with the Jupiter
project and separating kind of the
Python Colonel stuff and everything from
the front and the iPad know
book it's kind of a good indicator for
that many people are just at a
discussion before my presentation at
lunch is ipython and ide I mean in the
end it's not so I just call it powerful
I didn't know development environment
you could also say this kind of an
interactive exploratory tool that you
can use to interact with data you have
23 flavors so i'm using the apothem
shell and notebook quite intensively
critique console i think is not that
needed anymore in a sense in it but in
addition you need many other things of
course any kind of a decorated path and
distribution consistent so but once you
have that I mean this is kind of pretty
simple the only thing that needs a
license work somewhere measuring here is
sublime text but there many free editors
as well so like a spider but you can do
all the things that I present here today
even if you are just a student studying
finance and this kind of one of the
beauty for things when you're talking
about like interactive financial data
analytics nothing only for like large
hedge funds or large banks that have you
huge budgets and huge clusters or
whatever so this is something that you
can do even as a student at university
today on your machine and I can still
remember pretty well when I was studying
I had to go to my professor and I had to
pay for data that I needed so even as a
student had to pay for like regular
stock prices like that and these times
have fortunately changed actually just
my talk will be i would very very
briefly review what we are using in the
financial ecosystem but this kind of the
the standard scientific stack in the end
just remembering what what is kind of
the or what are the workforces that we
all rely on and then i will show how to
apply this in financial context and how
to process large data and large data can
mean that we have lots of historical
data stored on disk for example but it
can also mean and this is something we
are heavily involved in that you
simulate the future and that you heavy
monte carlo simulations where the data
doesn't sit maybe on the disk and you've
retrieve it but the data is generated on
the fly and you have to crunch like
gigabytes terabytes of data that is
generated just in time if you like many
many banks do these things or they have
to do it to regulatory reasons and you
dimensional reasons overnight
they have kind of really computationally
demanding things to implement but numpy
of course I mean we're at PI data s like
that I have to introduce an umpire but
just to remember it provides us with a
basic building block typically to store
data and in particular financial data so
the beauty comes not only that is kind
of a very efficient data store but you
have all the convenience that is a
vectorized operations you have
aggregation operations like the mean
standard deviation so typical things
that you need when you're doing finance
and or scientific things in Python but
was also of course when we talk about
interactive analytics the visualization
of data is also really really from my
point of view convenient in a sense of
course people are complaining that well
it's not that beautiful then as ggplot
from our and so forth but nevertheless I
mean here you have two lines of code and
you visualize the data that you want to
visualize even attach the method to your
to your numpy and the array object set
which kind of access you interested in
so even for student not being a
programmer or domain expert not being an
expert programmer it's pretty simple to
do the things that I present here today
but more often than not we have these in
the finance base but also in physics
many many other areas we have time
series data and not only like numerical
data and any kind of format like a
vector or matrix cube or even more
dimensions so pandas comes now into play
and I mentioned already pennis has its
origins in financial context so hedge
funds of course like any other nation
Institute have to deal with huge amounts
of time series data and West makini
couple of years ago started developing
panels at AQR Capital Management heavy
Python users still these days so many
many billions if not trillions of money
are managed based on Python programs so
it's also kind of maybe an indicator for
the success of course we can add to the
to the data that we have before kind of
a time index here generated with the
date range function such that in the end
we have a little bit more rich structure
where we have the daytime information
attached and what partners also provides
this kind of even a higher level of
abstraction even a higher level of
convenience and this is what brings all
so many people when I mentioned iPad
notebook for example people like it an
interaction and so forth that's for free
but what people bring two pandas it's
kind of the very high level abstraction
that the people can reach results pretty
pretty quickly by using what partners
actually provides in the end and again
it makes for example plotting even more
easy for my point of view ponders makes
a wonderful job unlike integrating the
wonderful libraries of the scientific
stack into one package where you say
what it relies on pie tables hdf5 for
data storage it relies on map lib for
plotting it uses numb expression for the
first evaluation and probably evaluation
of an American expression and so forth
so it's really it brings the high level
abstraction even one level higher if you
like and in the end you can have kind of
very complex analytic a task in a single
line of code and there are not too many
languages where you can say that I
mentioned already pie tables for how
about I oh it's kind of a very wonderful
i will be ft the main ortho here sitting
I see him Francesca welcome to the talk
why is it good to use 85 and fight
tables particular for financial data I
mean usually we are dealing in finance
with time series data and set it and
it's typically data that can be pretty
easily stored in tables that's a reason
why most of the functions used still
using relational databases so other data
but here you might have advantages by
using a different format than SQL
because everything needs to rely on the
complex relations on the complex SQL
queries and so forth but just to make a
brief example how you can get to a
hoverboard I oh you see here i generate
a and the array object with the
pseudo-random numbers here and this has
a size of a gigabyte the in-memory
generation takes nine seconds but the
one gigabyte of data here is written in
a little bit more than a second so using
SSD drives having a rewrite speed of as
of today like in this notebook 512
megabytes per second makes writing and
reading data faster than the MMO
generation of our array those kind of
amazing and when you think of things
like inter coming out with kind of
standard commodity as a sea trials
having a reading speeds of two gigabyte
per second and writing speeds of 1.5
gigabyte per second you can get these
for
I don't know around thousand yes this is
kind of real improvement when it gets to
IO and Python makes it pretty easy to
harness the power of the sale so getting
to Hardware bound io speeds is kind of
what makes a beauty at least from my
point of view because you're still
working in a very pythonic way they are
not tricksters not like low-level things
stuff that you have to do you can get
the results and you can get to the
machine that is available and to the
limits of the machine pretty pretty
easily he had a reading of course
there's some kind of buffering in place
the read speed is not that high but
buffering allows to really pretty pretty
fast here in this way in memory and see
the data frame that i read in here
really owns the data but let me come to
some applications i mean it's about
finance lot about a scientific stack but
all we've seen will now be applied to
financial contacts let us start with
kind of a very typical one of the
canonical examples and finances
portfolio optimization the problem of
saying well i have a universe of stocks
that i can invest in for example think
of attacks index or the S&P 500 or the
euro stoxx 50 index the major indices of
the world and you have a couple of
stocks of course included in there and
the question is what is kind of the
right mix what what is the best mix for
me in terms of like either minimizing
risk or getting the most out of it in
terms of return all the time so this is
what typically what investors are
interested in maybe the third dimension
might be to have kind of the right mix
between return and risk and here to make
it simple and to have not too many i am
using five symbols five if you say we he
killed stocks it's not only stocks as
also ETFs included in here which says
his apple stock we considered the google
stock the microsoft stock deutsche bank
from germany and also a certificate for
gold which kind of commodity product
where it he f's are a pretty easy way to
invest in so the question is now i have
this and have maybe a hundred thousand i
have a million to invest or even only if
that wasn't what is the best mix for me
given the historical performance of
these and this problem was actually
solved if you like or the first rigorous
statistical approach was invented back
then in the 50s 1952 and later on a
nobel prize was a water for that mark
it's one that which as well and
principal we only have to take care of
the standard deviation of the volatility
of the returns and of the respect of the
expected returns but let me come to that
after we have the data available so we
have decided upon five different symbols
here using pandas again on a very high
level I have the data reader function
which you find independence dot io data
sup library and I can pretty easily and
I mentioned the example of me being a
student having to pay a professor to
getting data so now you sit here and
your ipython notebook sure your internet
connection and you get the data if a
time frame is available or you ask for
and we get the closing data from Google
as a data source and we store it in a
data frame only a couple of lines of
code and we have the data four or five
symbols stored in there so now I can
pretty easily store that on disk and it
sees only it's not a large data set as a
small data set is written in 10
milliseconds here remember the lesser
just when it illustrates also pretty
easy to use PI tables wire upon us
because there again it's kind of a real
high level abstraction in the API built
in to Ponder's visualization is pretty
easy and you see here I also do a kind
of a vectorized operations that n
normalize the stocks of course or the
the investment vehicles in general
because it's not only stocks that i
mentioned i can do vectorized operations
pretty simple here in this case and you
see i have kind of now normalized plot
and you see Apple has performed the best
over the years unit if there was kind of
a bad period but i think deutsche bank
our german bank was the worst performing
but nevertheless might expect some kind
of diversification effect as we call it
in finance when we mix the portfolio so
usually would say if you're only
interested in kind of the highest return
then you would go with apple probably
because this hat over recent years the
best performance on average but just
also some kind of risk is he a blur has
been performing well but the volatility
you see kind of the minimum maximum the
drawdowns and so forth is of course a
little bit higher but let us get a
little bit more
reduce and former in this case I again
do a completely vectorized operation by
dividing the data frame by itself
shifted by one index day so it's kind of
a very compact way to calculate the lock
returns on a daily basis over a whole
data frame so there's nothing like a for
loop or whatsoever that you would
typically have to implement maybe using
another language as C C++ would be good
examples for that again calling a method
and scaling that I end up with the
annualized returns and they see here
dogger Bank was the worst performer and
I said Apple you've seen in chard is the
best performer but this something in
addition to consider when we talk about
portfolios is the decorrelation
covariance between the single stocks and
here see that even let's say a little
bit more complex statistics as as easily
calculated as the mean for example so
just calling the covariance method gives
you back a a frame with all the
different values given the stocks in in
the data frame actually but coming to
the mathematics and i only have included
that it's kind of not that important to
understand it at that point but what is
important when you do portfolio
analytics kind of the return of a whole
portfolio this is given mainly by the
weights that your sign the weight in a
sense I invest twenty percent and to
upload thirty percent in the Microsoft
or whatever in the end it should add up
to a hundred percent this is what in the
end is kind of a linear thing determines
what I can expect given the historical
performance if historical performance or
some kind of indicator for the future I
would say well they performed that in
the past and I expect this on average
for the future when it comes to the
resulting risk which means to the
variations to the volatility in the end
then the covariance plays a role here
you see kind of again the we've seen is
already numerically but here you see the
definition of the covariance matrix
again it's not that important to
understand it here just want to have the
mathematical representation and then
compare this to the Python
implementation in the end what is
important is the portfolio variance and
here you see that the covariance matrix
is kind of the major
input factor here and see this is what
was defined here and we use the
covariance matrix in the end to come up
with kind of a two x dot product again
the weights of course play a role and
given the covariance matrix we end up
with a variance value for the portfolio
that's the reason why it's called mean
variance so the mean return and the
variance of the portfolio which are in
the NT important statistic so I can put
all the calculations given my data frame
on a single slide so as little of
mathematics involved it will be the
original article I remember myself
sitting in library and going over this
doing it by pencil and paper it's pretty
hard but you see here using vectorized
approaches using numpy universal
functions and a dot function and
whatever stuff is is provided as
convenience method in the data frame you
see there's only a couple of lines of
code that I need actually this is only
to get to the weights to a random weight
distribution here so I don't decide upon
something just ran the radius diffusion
and this is the implementation of all
the mathematics yes it expected
portfolio return they expect to
portfolio variance so it's actually only
two lines of code to get the mathematics
right in this case and here is kind of
the volatility because typically you
rather want to measure it in volatility
term standard deviation and not in
variance but this is just an additional
line of code if you like but two lines
of code to implement in a highly
vectorized fashion the whole mathematics
applied to that but let us have a look
here we only do monte carlo simulation
drawing 2500 random portfolio wait so to
say it's kind of the monkey thing i've
ever heard of that the Wall Street
Journal did does it fall since 50 years
of what where they have the monkey
throwing a dart to the the wall street
journal and then this is what what the
what the monkey and the spots is kind of
picked to a portfolio and the market the
monkey almost ever won against the most
professional portfolio managers so it's
kind of the reasoning that the market is
efficient and even if you analyze
whatever you want to analyze you can't
beat the market and the monkey in that
sense is the market because it's like
randomly selecting something and this is
what we're doing here we just randomly
select out of the possible combinations
and you see it here like the
distribution in terms of expected
turn vs expected volatility and the
Sharpe ratio is actually in simplified
fashion here that we divide the expected
return like ten percent per annum by the
expected volatility like twenty percent
on an annual basis and you get the ratio
here in colors because this is kind of
the investors measure the higher the
Sharpe ratio better the single measure
expected return nor the single measure
expected volatility doesn't mean that
much but the combination of both means
already quite a lot so you will always
target for the red ones not the blue
ones they are cold freezing isn't and
the best of the red ones are the good
then you're hot in the market but there
is not actually what you're looking for
kind of random distributions when you're
doing this statistical implementations
you want to optimize things and optimize
in that sense means given a certain risk
of the portfolio want to have the
highest return or the other way around
given a fixed return or a target return
you want to minimize the risk so of
course you have to fix one to optimize
the other and this is what we're doing
here right now using this app optimized
a function and there recently like
generalized the minimize function where
we can have constrained optimizations JC
we have two equations that we use
certain methods we provide boundaries
for the acid weights and in the end
you'll fully end up with something
optimal and here you see the efficient
frontier and this is actually what we're
interested in the crosses lots of dots
the dots were random and of course the
random ones they sometimes hit the
efficient frontier but more often than
not did I hit the efficient frontier so
this is what you're interested in when
you're doing portfolio analytics this
actually lying I say well given a
certain risk I can get the highest
return or the other way around given a
certain given a certain target return
this is the minimum risk and here you
will find the minimum variance or
minimum volatility put for you coming to
another application principal component
analysis who view uses PCA and it is not
only used in finance this is kind of a
standard method so a couple of year so
want to do is kind of
determining the principal components and
reproducing the performance of a index
because an index the stock index like a
duck's is composed of 30 stocks in the
case of the tax and of course the
performance of the 30 stocks of the
Ducks make up the performance of the of
the overall index but principal but they
are of course highly correlated so for
what we want to do is kind of to derive
prints of principal components that are
not correlated but are linear
combinations of the single assets
included in there and to like try to
replicate the performance of the of the
index actually this is an approach used
by a couple of investment managers a
certain kind of investment approach that
I say well let us determine the
principal components and we use these
because they are not correlated to for
example mimic the performance of Linux
here we work right now with a little bit
more data this is actually indeed the
dax index and all the 30 names the
ticker symbols are you included and
again I read it in the two lines of code
I read in all the symbols 31 to 30 plus
the ducks in a highly vectorized fashion
once again I determine i calculate the
lock returns and I drop not number
values because the the PCA function
doesn't work with it so i get rid of not
number of values because we're doing the
lock returns and so forth n minus there
might be a couple of these so pretty
convenient and in the end we have
something like this you see the time
series here on the left hand side you
see the single names and this kind of
larger huge matrix 30 name 30 columns
and over a period of four years or three
and a half years in this case we pick
out or take out pop out the ducks here
in this case you see the distribution
the frequency distribution of the Ducks
returns obviously not normal we have fat
tails with high peaks and so forth so
the basic assumption of most financial
models fails even for the most common
indices but nevertheless let us work
with it let us implement the PCA we
scale the data to have zero mean and one
standard deviation then fit the data to
our scale function here
the color pca from this I could learn
library and in the end what I do is kind
of determine the explanatory power and
here you see the first ten principal
components it's ten but this year it
says five this is a mismatch it's the
first ten that I pig out yet they
explained more than seventy five percent
of the movement when you do it with with
the values and up with the returns with
the original value of surprise values
then you get even for the first
component like a ninety percent
explanatory power but let us have a look
so here using only one component the
most yet the principal component so to
say you see that we can already pretty
well replicate the performance over time
starting in 2010 up until recently by
this single component so I see a linear
good linear combination of the
underlying factors provides you already
with a high level of explanation here
using many more doesn't make that much
of a difference we have seen it before
the first ten stand for like
seventy-five percent explanatory power
but again you see all the kind of rather
complex things are applied pretty easily
to the pandas dataframe and here the the
plotting for example you see kind of a
row and application of certain methods I
select two columns out of a data frame
then I calculate the cumulative sum I
apply the scale function and then the
result which is a data frame is plotted
so I see is a single line of code as I
mention before you have really high
level abstraction well I want to
community of some then I apply this and
that so you don't have single steps for
that the procedural you have really the
the object-oriented method based call
that and this I think can even be
understood by as i said before students
or non-experts so call them probably
expert i mentioned that python is a good
partner when it comes to harnessing the
power of the available yeah hardware and
then the capabilities at the hardware as
of today provides so probably a process
simulation something that's also really
important for us because the
the case where we simulate stuff in the
future we use Monte Carlo simulation and
there is a huge benefit by paralyzing
the code I had a similar example it
might performance by the talk on
Wednesday at your Python and it was
mentioned that this is a simple case yes
it is a simple case but it's kind of a
case did you encounter at least in
finance quite often that you have they
have a data and code parallelism in a
sense that the same function the same
simulation function has to be executed
multiple times actually and the data is
not like shared or whatever I want to
skip through that the function itself is
not that not that interesting to be
honest here you see a simple simulation
this is kind of we've worked with
historical data this tries to like mimic
a potential future behavior of a stock
index or of anything else and
graphically this might look like this
for example but what is more important
how can we paralyze that and pattern has
to build in volume multiprocessing which
can be easily used at least on a single
local machine and we all have as of
today even though our notebooks multi
because that we can use if you've maybe
a larger server it's more efficient but
here what we do is kind of simulate a
hundred task you do 100 simulations and
I've done this on a server with eight
cores so I I change the number from 1 up
until eight so I add one worker after
the other to end up with eight cores in
the end and the only thing I have to do
is here kind of mapping my function that
if defined previously for the simulation
to the data set that I put into the is
similar to de to the Python map that you
might know like map filter reduced or
for kind of functional programming
approach in Python a couple of lines of
cording to see here the harnessing of
the power of multiple cores is pretty
easy NEC kind of really the the benefits
that the polarization for this
particular example brings so Python
again is only a couple of lines of code
and it can harness the power that the
hardware allows you to do even in
interactive context there's nothing that
has to be scheduled or whatsoever so as
a student you can sit there and do the
same things that I'm doing here probably
Monte Carlo simulation is just an
example using a class-based
implementation for an option pricing
formula
option pricing formula from pricing
approach a little bit different but in
the end it boils down to the same thing
a little bit more flexible just to
illustrate that it works with other
approaches as well again you see I met
my workout which wraps a method of my of
my object here to again a set of data so
livid different syntax little bit
different approach but in the end it
boils down to the very same approach and
obviously also to the very same results
in the end so lots of data of course
this data parallelism with the lots of
data to be simulated makes it necessary
that you have enough RAM so I was
running this on a machine with 64
gigabytes of RAM but still as of today
64 gigabytes or 128 gigabytes are not
that expensive anymore so this data
parallelism is probably easily
implemented another example that I want
to show you briefly is processing large
csv files and this was brought to me by
one of my clients and well we are
sitting from client being a top
management consultancy company that we
have trained there were introduced
python and say well we are often sitting
at clients and it provides us you CSV
files but we can't really process them
because they're like 50 gigabytes large
and we only have our machines with for 8
gigabytes of RAM so that's sitting at
the client side with the desktops having
no machines that the data is not allowed
to like leave the building if you like
okay say well using SAS we can like
process these files I don't know how to
do it and then python that we
Illustrated that so this is kind of an
example that works with CSV files that
are too large to fit into memory
actually we need a couple of imports
nothing special about that and we do
here is kind of generate an in-memory
data set with see it here 10 million
rows in the end right in the data part
of it integers part of it silent
normally distributed and we will now
generate a CSV file out of that and you
see writing this 10 x such that we end
up with a hundred million rows this is
not big data would say but maybe
large data mid-sized data takes 22
minutes so the writing of data out of
memory like using standard Python
writing a text file putting all the data
throwing all the data in text 22 minutes
just as a as a benchmark value we delete
the original objects we don't need them
anymore just having a look at the CSV
file of course pretty easy to read like
the first 5 lines out of it well this
looks like as intended we have we have a
date time information that we have two
integers and then we have two floats so
it's kind of a typical thing they will
encounter for example in finance we have
for example for your positions or
whatever we say well I have 10 products
of this you have the product ID number
then you have the maybe the base
currency in euro and you have the
accounting currency in US for example
could be a typical data set and then you
have the movement over time the changes
and so we end up with the time series
and here we have again 100 million lines
of such data now what can we do reading
and writing with pandas is one approach
I want to do is kind of taking a data
out of the CSV of the text-based world
and storing it in a more convenient
format to this end pandas 3gs file
function plan allows to generate an
iterator object such that we don't have
to read in the data as a whole we can do
it chunk wise as we used to like by
iterating line by line over an open file
so here but we can do larger chunk size
what I do is kind of twentieth of my
original file size n which was ten
million so it's kind of not large but
not that's more so we would expect kind
of an efficient reading process here but
let us do the reading process and here
you see reading the data into memory and
appending it to our disk based data
frame here you see appended to data
chunk and get the size of pd name pd
name is the name of the file on this
takes five minutes and 14 seconds and
the whole process crunches 12 gigabytes
of data in this case your recent data
set is six gigabytes large I have to
read in six petabytes of data and a
right to disk
givers of data and this takes five
minutes compared to the 22 minutes for
only one direction if you like for only
the writing part of that now we have an
hdf5 file which is called h5 here with a
hundred million rows and the five
columns as we've seen before and this is
memory efficient in a sense that you can
do with 50 gigabytes in the same fashion
of course it would take a little bit
longer but it works even on a small
desktop if you have enough storage
capacity on your HDD or STD now you can
do if now memories allows this isn't now
and like reversing the D perspective
because I've implemented not on a
machine with 4 gigabyte and such a
machine 60 I won't fit it was
implemented on the machine with 64
gigabytes I can do like this base
analytics with pandas so this is six
gigabytes large and I can just call on
my object on disk the described method
you see this takes three minutes
actually have to crunch the data because
pandas doesn't do it like pie tables
there's not like a memory efficient
thing that reads it in it crunches it
and then provides a result I can also
plot like select the data you see here I
have the the object on disk I only take
the column which is called flow to I
only take the first ten the first
thousand rows I apply the cumulative sum
method I and then I plot it so again we
have this high level abstraction and
single line of code no procedural it's
kind of sing line of code and I get a
result for the first thousand values of
the flow to column out of my disk space
file now what I have a look at edit we
see that it's not kind of stored in a
fashion that you would like it this is
only important to understand the pie
tables example that come you see here
that we have a values block 0 1 2 and so
this is not kind of a stringent storage
procedure from my point of view this
could be improved for performance
reasons because you see the two float
columns and the two integer columns are
like mingle together so this prevents a
couple of may be useful analytical
approaches but let us see how it could
work when we only use PI tables in this
case using pi table similar thing we
open a file for writing
we define a complex data type numpy data
type for the day to integer column flow
column and so forth this data type you
use to create a table using a little bit
of compression here compression another
two and the plus compression library and
what we do here at now is again using
the iterator object from the read CSV
function provided by pandas actually but
now we are not storing it in upon this
data frame on disk now we are storing
the data that we retrieved from this
into a pie tables table and you see this
is equally fast four minutes 28 seconds
again 12 gigabytes crunched 22 minutes
for the CSV file one direction you have
two two directions and four minutes 28
seconds now having a look at the data on
disk we see we now have the clear
structure that we would like to have
five columns typical tables kind of the
original data looks like now in PI
tables as you would like to have it and
not like commingled something bye-bye
ponders this data on this can now be
used like any Python object like any
numpy and the area and the array object
that is I can do slicing row wise for
example this is all on disk that I can
select kind of the robot thing and then
only the data points toward and date for
example I can for example calculate the
length I don't have to do it there's
metadata but just to illustrate it kind
of an aggregation operation here in this
case and this is pretty efficient given
the given the point that it's out of
memory and here see also the 3.7 seconds
for taking the sum over a whole column
or the mean of a whole column similar
operation similar performance if you
like and also some SQL like as i like to
call them conditions and queries can be
added but I said well give me all the
values of the flow to column for every
road that that fulfills the following
conditions flow 1 is greater than three
integer to smaller than a thousand and
so forth so you can have other memory
operations which are really
efficient on data sets that are pretty
large and this can be even implemented
on machines again where the data set
might not fit into memory and this was
actually what I was asked and it's
pretty pretty helpful when you say well
I have stored the data in that format
and I can I'm only interested in kind of
only chunks of the data and this of
course improves performance I think
Francesca I mentioned a couple of these
approaches in this regard also in his
talk and he's given a talk after me I
think so he will learn more about all
these nice approaches in historic
actually conclusions Python libraries
such as numpy pond despite tables
nothing new to you I just wanted to
illustrate how they are used as of today
or can be beneficially used in financial
context provide useful means and
approaches to work with large even big
financial data in some circumstances I
think the the libraries and the Python
world itself so there has a couple of
very very powerful advantage is kind of
the high level abstraction you've seen
we haven't had that much kind of queries
or plotting commands with multiple lines
it was the only single line of code
typically numerical performance is
usually pretty high so we can get
usually to the speeds of see women doing
it right not always of course it's not a
point but if you're doing it right it is
performant and often performant enough
it's what counts and i/o performance
which is also pretty pretty important at
least in a in a financial context it's
also getting better and better and
potatoes for example partners and debts
and makes it pretty convenient to
harness the power of today's hardware
and again I mentioning here kind of the
two or one gigabyte reading writing
speeds that today's SSDs can bring to
the table in a sense even at low prices
as low that even researchers and
universities can afford to use them
thanks for your attention more than
happy to take questions
thank you very much Eve for that
interesting talk perhaps we have time
for one or two questions there is a
microphone over there if you don't want
to use it and we'll have to repeat the
question Maricopa in terms of the
question is what is missing at the
moment in terms of infrastructure from
my point of view not that much what is
missing in a certain sense that we've
been working with a couple of large
furniture institution that this regard
is kind of all the let's say enterprise
oriented application frameworks to
deploy python applications i am at the
moment I don't have the feeling that
there's that much missing on an
analytical scientific level the
scientific stack is already well worst
if you want to point to something
missing there it's kind of two things
the documentation and may be related to
that kind of changing api's over time so
pine nuts for example as nice as it is
from one version to the other you always
have to have Tate it your code and this
is nothing that institutions would like
to have you know it's kind of always
want to be at the current state but you
don't want to update the API as
documentation and also support but there
are companies like continuum analytics
for example or n thought provide
distributions where you can also get
professional support oh this is getting
better but from my point of view what I
see in from the scale is kind of d but
people i use from the Java world you
know it's kind of these multi-million
projects when they have these use
application servers and infrastructures
so everything around when you want to do
it on large scale this is not that good
at the moment as it could be but again
we've done lots of things in this regard
for financial institutions and I think
in the future this will be better as
well there was one other question maybe
yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure the couple of
reasons the question is in the analytics
space most banks you C++ for
implementing computationally demanding
and performance critical analytical
tasks and this is I mean the reason pass
it was kind of one of the the only
choices that allowed you to do it in an
efficient and performant way at the time
when pison hasn't had faisan number and
all the things that I presented on
Wednesday my performance Python talk I
think Python as of today has all the
ingredients as what I was saying before
if you would start to implement an
analytics library for derivatives CVA
analytics risk analytics whatever you
would better go with Python and using
all the things that are available and
now it makes it I think by a factor of
two three four five more efficient than
doing it in C++ also maintenance and so
forth why do banks stick to the
analytics libraries I mean this is like
almost always a legacy thing a large
investment bank having a complex product
heavily traded of a couple of years you
might have a single class single kind of
valuation Colonel if you like for this
one financial product that might have
120,000 lines of code in C++ where
multiple developers are maintaining this
single piece of the library that this is
not that easy to replace even if you say
well in Python this will be only let's
say fifteen thousand lines of code and
it would be as performant but it is in
production it runs you know it's kind of
this is a legacy thing in the end many
many hedge funds as of today quant hedge
funds doing trading risk and so forth
are starting out with Python when they
can start out when it started from
scratch if there is something that they
encounter which is still too slow and
Python for whatever reason then they use
boost or whatever to like integrate C++
and interface we see using thighs on all
the approaches that's fine but
overall I mean bank of america is a good
example having 10 million lines of
Python code in production for the risk
management platform it works but
analytics again I agree with you is in
C++ but mainly due to the fact that you
have more people who can do c++ and
dixie of legacy code and yeah of course
what we all know out of all the
corporations that we might have in mind
ok so let's thankee once again thank you
you